je me présente la lourde fabiola j'aurai
49 ans à la fin de l'année je suis élu à
la mairie de la possession
dans la délégation de la petite enfance
de l'intergénérationnel et de la
jeunesse et nouvellement élu conseiller
départemental dans la commission
permanente
présidente de la commission de la
jeunesse et de l'insertion
membre de la commission des solidarités
et de la cohésion sociale titulaire de
la commission d'appel d'offres titulaire
de la commission de délégation de
service public
je suis originaire du chaudron donc j'ai
vécu dans les toute la plus grande
partie de ma vie jusqu'à mai
44 ans au chaudron à saint denis
je suis dans la ville de la possession
c'est une ville d'adoption j'y suis
depuis quatre ans et c'est là où je
m'épanouis est vraiment puisque c'est
une ville où il fait bon vivre dans un
cadre agréable et où voilà le côté
verdure le côté
comment on dire biodiversité est encore
présente et j'adore cd
les priorités c'est mettre en place
notre permanence la permanence des
conseillers départementaux qui pour moi
me semble être une priorité
puisque nous nous devons être à faire la
proximité avec nos administrés ils ont
demander si tu nous demandes et nous
notre devoir c'est d'être au plus près
de nous de nos administrés de nos
citoyens en ce qui concerne aussi la
culture moi j'ai une
c'est un voilà c'est quelque chose qui
me tient vraiment à coeur notamment je
parle de culture non pas en termes de
maloya voilà en tant que tel mais le
patrimoine notre patrimoine réunionnais
notre biodiversité notre
savoir faire et savoir être le
comment dire
la langue la langue notre langage causé
également est très important à mes yeux
et je souhaite mettre en place un
conseil culturel réunionnais pour
promouvoir et défendre notre langue
culturelle notre langue réunionnaise
aussi à
la jeunesse moi je suis dans la version
et la jeunesse je suis présidente de
cette commission il ya un gros travail à
faire notamment faire en sorte de la
lutte contre les inégalités contre les
injustices en matière de formation
d'éducation de
d'emploi de mutation nous devons
vraiment être plus près de nos jeunes
les aider alors quand on parle de jeunes
c'est vrai qu'on dit souvent les jeunes
les jeunes mais je crois qu'il faut
prendre le jeune dans sa globalité dans
le foyer la famille et le choc il ya
aussi
notre population sur la peau sur la pole
et la possession elle est vieillissante
aujourd'hui nous devons commencer à
travailler sur faire en sorte que nos
gramounes puisse rester chez eux le plus
longtemps possible
lorsque ce n'est pas possible faire en
sorte que les familles d'accueil les
ehpad les pensions marron que ses pairs
que ces établissements-là ces
institutions là soient accompagnés et
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent aider au
maximum les personnes chemin notamment
des pensions maru jeudi l'accompagnement
des pensions marron parce que il faut
pas oublier que s'étend sur ma roue ont
été créés parce qu'il n'y avait plus de
place dans les ehpad n'avait plus de
place dans les familles d'accueil ou
dans les autres institutions pour
accueillir un hologramme eux
pour améliorer effectivement la qualité
de vie dans l'avenir pour nous
réunionnais le département a un grand
rôle à jouer notamment ce travail de
proximité
être au plus près des réunionnais
comprendre leurs difficultés et pouvoir
les écouter c'est la priorité la
première des choses c'est vraiment les
écouter écouter les familles d'accueil
écoutez les étals écoutez les comment
dire les personnes porteuses de handicap
et puis voir leur quotidien ce
s'imprégner de leur quotidien pour sa
entendre réellement quelles sont les
difficultés pour ces personnes je pense
que ça c'est vraiment un premier pas à
faire pour pour connaître pour avant de
trouver des solutions et de vouloir et
de vouloir avancer c'est vraiment
revenir aux bases voir quelles sont les
difficultés que rencontrent nos
réunionnais est vraiment s'y attarder
dessus